- [Voiceover] So we
have the function f of x
is equal to x to the sixth
minus three x to the fifth
and we want to know over what
intervals is f decreasing
and we're going to do
it without even having
to graph y equals f of x
and the way we do that is
we look at the derivative
of f with respect to x
and think about, well, when
is that less than zero?
If the rate of change
of f with respect to x
is less than zero, well
over those intervals
it will be decreasing.
So let's first take the derivative.
So f prime of x is going to be equal to,
just use the power rule here,
it's going to be six x to the fifth power
minus five times three is 15 x to the,
let's decrease that exponent by one,
x to the fourth power
and so let's think about
when this is going to be less than zero.
Over what intervals is six x to the fifth
minus 15 x to the fourth less than,
less than zero?
So let's see, we could factor
out a three x to the fourth,
so three x to the fourth times,
see if we factor out a
three x to the fourth here,
we'll just be left with a two x minus five
is less than zero.
Did I do that right?
Let's see, if I were to distribute it,
three times two is six,
x to the fourth times x
is x to the fifth, three times five is 15
and x to the fourth, yep, that's right
so if I'm getting the
product of two things
and I want it to be less than zero,
well, there's only way for that to happen
is that one or I guess you could say
there's two ways for that to happen.
Either the first thing is positive
and the second is negative
or the first is negative
and the second is positive
and so let's do that.
So either, either three x to the fourth
is negative
and,
and two x minus five is positive
or,
let me just put the or
in a separate color here,
or three x to the fourth
is positive
and
two x minus five is negative.
So let's see.
This is x to the fourth,
three x to the fourth
being less than zero.
Well, if we divide both sides by three,
this is just going to be x to the fourth
needs to be less than zero.
And is there any way for something to be
to the fourth power to be less than zero?
Well, we're assuming we're
dealing with real numbers here
and any real number to the fourth power
is going to be greater
than or equal to zero
so it's actually impossible
for something to the fourth
power to be less than zero.
This thing is never,
this thing is never going
to be less than zero
so we can actually rule
out this first case.
So we can rule out that
first case right over there.
And so we're only going
to worry about this case.
So three x to the fourth
being greater than zero,
well, that's going to happen as long as
x is not equal to zero.
So this is,
because for any other x,
this is going to be true.
x could be negative.
You take it to the fourth
power, multiply it by three,
it's going to be greater than zero
so this is really just the condition
that x cannot be equal to zero.
And let's see the second one,
two x minus five less than zero,
that means two x is going
to be less than five
and then x
is less than five halves.
So as long as x is less than five halves
and x is not equal to zero,
this thing will be decreasing.
So if we wanted to write it in terms of,
it we wanted to write it
in terms of intervals,
we could say x is,
let me do this in a new color
just to ease the monotony.
So we could say that,
having trouble picking a color,
so we could say that x is less than zero
or zero is less than x
is less than five halves.
So x is less than zero, this
is all the negative values
and then we're essentially
just excluding zero
and then going all the way to,
all the way to five halves
and remember, all I did is say,
well, when is our first
derivative negative
because if the first
derivative is negative
then the rate of change of f
with respect to x is negative
or f is decreasing as x is increasing.